they're on the front lines of the
coronavirus crisis health care workers
testing the limits of human endurance
even making the ultimate sacrifice
we knew coverage was coming
and in my wildest dreams I never
imagined how devastating and hard it
would be after the struggle to contain
the pandemic what will it mean for
healthcare systems and the people who
run them
the burden of tackling a global health
crisis has fallen more heavily on the
shoulders of one group than any other
the world's health care workers are
dealing with death and disease on a
daily basis risking their own health at
the same time and not always with the
level of protection that they need he
waved goodbye to his colleagues at the
end of his shift olivier Lebovitz has
been a nurse for 30 years he works in
one of the largest hospitals in Paris
the upbeat aisle kosher right in the
city centre Lebovitz looks after up to
12 patients a day on the geriatric ward
his net income is one thousand seven
hundred and thirty five euros per month
for months now there's been virtually no
time at all to pause for a break the
core need to so don't have you said I'm
the only one working at my station and
have to do everything myself there are
doctors and other nurses but there's a
lot to do I hardly get a break I barely
have enough time for a cup of coffee in
the afternoon
he's witnessed how the corona virus
pandemic pushed the French healthcare
system to the brink there were dramatic
scenes at hospitals with shortages of
all types of supplies ventilators
personal protective equipment masks
medical staff worked courageously
pushing themselves to sheer exhaustion
many hospital workers became sick
themselves and some even died the system
nearly collapsed we're not prepared for
such a wave of pandemic not at this
intensity or duration olivier Lebovitz
agrees after budget cuts and reforms
French hospitals were left with
insufficient emergency room capacity and
not enough staff doctors and nurses had
to work around the clock Papo coded 19
crises made working conditions even
worse I'm not the only one all of us
noticed just how badly things in France
have deteriorated the response every
night at 8:00 the French have gone out
on to their balconies to applaud medical
workers the movement that spread across
the country during the stringent
lockdown musical performances mobilized
entire neighborhoods people were
conscious of the crisis playing out from
the hospitals
[Music]
Fatman UL McCoy admitted mistakes were
made
hospital budget cuts have been too
drastic administration too sluggish to
react staff too poorly paid now CGT the
influential health care workers union is
calling for raises of at least 300 euros
and for the retirement age to be lowered
to 55
Olivier leverage supports this many more
funding resources and personnel but
above all else we need higher wages so
he's off to protest even though the
French government has just promised to
increase wages considerably and reform
the health care system well let's speak
to Professor James buckin he's editor in
chief of the publication human resources
for health and speaks to us from
Edinburgh professor Buchan this really
has been a tough time for healthcare
workers even beyond the sheer volume of
patients they're having to deal with
hasn't it very much so what has done is
expose any weaknesses in health systems
and health workforce numbers and
deployment and we're coming out of the
initial impact of Corbett with many of
the same workforce problems that existed
before could impacted and the sort of
problems we've been seeing are also the
health implications for the workers
themselves some countries doing a better
job of protecting their workers than
others we've seen that in the figures
haven't we we have indeed health workers
are at the frontline they are a high
risk of exposure the International
Council of nurses which has done some
good work in analyzing the variation in
infection rates suggests that on average
about 7% of nurses have been affected
across the front 30 countries they are
data for but that varies from below 1%
in Singapore up to above 20% in Spain
and to the countries that are on the
wrong side of those numbers have
anything in common is it a case of
million of PPE is a case of Under
laughing do we know I think there are
several contributory factors it's always
difficult to isolate one and and use
that as a explanation but availability
of PPE was a big problem and continues
to be a problem in some countries that's
heightened the risk of exposure where
there have been shortages and staff
individuals have had to work close to
patients for longer for longer periods
of time and that has also been
heightening the risk of exposure what
about health systems themselves we've
seen them performing to varying
different degrees around the world are
there particular models of health system
that have shown themselves to be
effective in a pandemic like this I
don't think a specific form or model
guarantees success but I think we can
point to systems which have a localised
flexible ability to respond to
differential impact in different parts
of the country as being one which is
better suited than top-down or really
centralized one I think we will see this
become even more of an issue as spikes
of Cobert occur locally within countries
it's the ability to respond quickly
locally that will be what is required to
try and deal with this next phase and
for the types of system where it maybe
hasn't worked as well as it could have
is there a positive outlook because
presumably if you've been underfunding
your system thus far you're not now
financially in a better position to do
it given the effect of coronavirus on
economies kabuto brutally exposed the
gaps in health systems and health
systems funding and as you say the risk
now is that the countries that have been
worst hit by Cobert are those who also
need to find more resources to make good
back economic damage and there is a
double whammy there high impact Cooke
ovid most negative impact on economy
well professor Falken has been
fascinating talking to you thanks for
your time that's professor James book
and editor-in-chief of human resources
for
thank you very much and now it's the
part of the program where you get to ask
the questions here's our science
correspondent Derek Williams can kovat
nineteen cause bad breath halitosis can
be caused by a wide range of different
factors from inadequate dental hygiene
to to a more serious underlying
condition but the w-h-o doesn't list it
as a symptom for kovat 19 however there
is an interesting connection between bad
breath and and the virus mouthwash sales
have spiked during the pandemic which I
guess was to be expected I mean plenty
of people probably hope that using mouth
washes regularly will have a
preventative effect even though there's
currently no evidence that gargling with
them protects you either that or or
breathing into a mask all the time has
made people hyper aware of how their own
breath smells can you catch kovat 19
from drinking unfiltered tap water
there's no evidence you can get kovat 19
from drinking treated water and and the
risk of transmission through water in
general even untreated wastewater
appears to be very low even when the
viruses genetic material can be detected
in untreated water in most cases it's
probably not viable
that's because Tsarskoe of to is what's
called an enveloped virus which means it
has a pretty fragile membrane that
doesn't really protect it for very long
outside the body so so standard
treatment methods used in most municipal
drinking water systems like like
filtration and
and disinfection should inactivate it
just like they do other pathogens if you
don't have access to safe treated water
than then the standard precautions that
you take like like boiling your drinking
water should also kill any SARS Cove -
why does Cambodia have no deaths from
kovat 19 as of this morning at least
there have still been only around a
hundred and forty cases of kovat 19
reported in Cambodia and not a single
official death no with a record like
that there's of course a lot of
speculation the country is is under
reporting none of it confirmed but if
the official numbers are accurate then
then Cambodia has has a remarkable
record so far as does neighboring
Vietnam both countries have been praised
by the w-h-o for for how they detected
and responded to new cases at a very
early stage of the pandemic with
extensive contact tracing and travel
restrictions and quarantine as early as
January a time when when most other
countries weren't willing to even
consider them at the time those measures
were viewed as as extreme but
retrospectively they look like something
that that everyone should have been
doing
[Music]
as our science correspondent Derrick
Williams now they've certainly proven
their worth during the corona virus
pandemic but many health care workers
remain some of their least well-paid in
their society's resistance to that fact
though is growing not least in Spain
around ten thousand nurses staged a
demonstration on Monday against their
levels of pay and temporary contracts
and they made their point with a moving
rendition of the 80s pop song resist
earache which translates as I will
resist and enjoy the music this has been
the cover 19 special thanks for joining
us
[Music]